what keeps you going what inspires you
think about my old job I always say that
because I hated it
and I just had an idea of like what do i
what if I do like a mockumentary about
what it's like to be black at Stanford I
think when you do something on your own
first thing you show that you're serious
and people will come the motivation
watch a top 10 with believe nation
what's that belief nation it's Evan I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so let's get your
motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and chew
in today's lessons from a woman who went
from working a bunch of odd jobs and
struggling whether to go to business or
law school to finding success with her
YouTube web series awkward black girl
and then creating and starring in her
own highly successful HBO series he's
Issa Rae and here's my take on her top
10 rules a success vol 2 also if you
want to know what successful leaders
like Oprah Winfrey Serena Williams
Michelle Obama and others have to say
about excellence check out my 254 black
excellent series where every day for the
next 254 days I will send you a morning
video for free shining light on
excellence in the black community the
link to join is in the description below
they think that success is supposed to
happen like that addicts sometimes you
you're gonna be your own cheerleader and
you have to be your biggest in your best
cheerleader because Oxford is a place
where dreams can come true
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one don't waste time what keeps you
going what inspires you and you know it
keeps you going um think about my old
job I always say that because I hated it
I hated waking up to go to that job I
like just felt like I was just wasting
time like I was like what am I not doing
when I feel like I'm supposed to be
doing and why can't I do it why can't I
get there and then you know I'm waking
up you know I tell the story about like
waking up at I think I have to wake up
at like 8 a.m. to be at the job by 9:00
and I was like this is so early on and
I'm just struggling and I'm dragging my
feet and Nina now I happily wake up at
like 5:00 to do something I love and
just even seeing that the difference
there of just like wanting to do
something but I always think about that
whenever I do get frustrated if you like
girl you could still be in Koreatown so
think about that rule number 2
collaborate what is some advice that you
can give women who are trying to find
their way I always advise them to work
with other young women like work with
the woman who just as hungry as you are
passionate and and form a team and form
a bond and commit yourselves to one
another because there's that's basically
what I've done you know I have such a
strong group of people who we've been
able to grow together
I wouldn't trade that in for anything
it's so much better than you know trying
to reach out and constantly say hey help
to put me on it's just like it's about
building your own thing and growing from
there rule number three be yourself
where did you find the strength to be so
honest with your art you seem to be so
steadfastly yourself and it's refreshing
thank you where they're coming from
the necessity just feeling like I wanted
to put what I wanted to see out there
you know I was complaining a lot about
what I wasn't seeing and you know an
internet commenter when I had a blog it
was just like you talk a lot of mess you
know why don't you do something and I
think that also empowered me to be like
yes and then the validation of people
responding to the work only adds to the
confidence so so were you always kind of
a stand-up person stand-up and with that
speaking your mind
oh no I've been passive-aggressive and I
think within a certain group of people
but I think I've had to come in to
openly speaking my mind I'm very
reserved in shy
for the most part rule number four be
patient I was doing like videography
gigs and editing gigs here and there cuz
I thought like oh if I edit this video
if I do the videography for this wedding
and edit it maybe like a movie director
will see it and be like you got skills
and I'll get discovered I was just going
about it the wrong way but even with
that web series I was just like
consistent about trying to release it at
the Monday at 10:00 every morning we
were promoting it constantly and that
was just like you know just didn't take
off in the same way and so once awkward
black girl took off and got attention I
was like oh this is it this is gonna
happen and then there's just so many
other steps you know I got the
opportunity to work with shaundalyn at
ABC and then I thought that was gonna be
my big break and it wasn't cuz I just
wasn't ready for it and then um I had
other webseries opportunities as I
thought that medium was gonna grow and
become more mainstream and that didn't
happen and so luckily when the ABC door
shut HBO called and said hey we heard
you're free do you have anything that
you want to pitch to us and
in security even that when I when I got
that opportunity may have bought that
show it's a three years for it to be
made so it took a lot of time rumor five
don't lose your voice I wonder if there
was ever a moment for you when you felt
like up against the line of like well
maybe I'm gonna make this compromise
because it will be some leap forward or
was it always for you because you came
from a writing perspective like very
clear that I'm sure that I would like
extremely broke time if I do this right
now you know then I can you know that I
can have the integrity later and I think
you know just even within the
development process you know in and
being given an opportunity you know when
you've created opportunities for either
a very low budget or just on a lower
level I felt like in once given the
opportunity I I strove to kind of to to
please in a way in a way that I wouldn't
have ever done before because I felt
like oh this is the only opportunity I'm
gonna have to be able to do this and so
I should try to fit into what is
expected of me and I've noticed I mean
that didn't work out you know because
for me that that led to becoming
voiceless and kind of just like I felt
like play-doh like I could be motive him
to anything and that's not why I was
hired or brought into the room in the
first place and so I've had to learn to
to get a voice and to make sure that I
don't you know fault that my voice
doesn't fall by the wayside that was a
journey Italy so rule number six take
action on your ideas some time off of
school to go to film school because
Stanford in have a film program so much
of New York Film Academy in LA and that
made that meant that I was behind on all
my studies and so the last quarter I
took like 20 units which was a lot I
think 22 units I had to petition to take
more classes and so I was really busy
which man I met had a lot of work and
when I have a lot of work my creative
mind goes in overdrive because I'm just
looking for an outlet and I just had an
idea of like what do i what if I do like
a mockumentary about what it's like to
be black as day
and created a webseries dorm Diaries and
it spread to a whole bunch of different
colleges and it was also during in time
when I was trying to break into the
industry traditionally by doing contests
we submitted for like a Sundance program
and was just getting knows and so to see
that show spread was like in a pay for
this moment where I feel like oh my gosh
I can just have direct access to an
audience and then I created another web
series featuring my younger brother and
then the third web series was Locker
black girl and that's the one that took
off and once I got attention for that
just from so many people supporting it
on the web that's when I got the
attention of like Pharrell and ABC and
then HBO came knocking for what we came
insecure rule number seven find balance
so you still feel like you face a few
challenges you still got to go through
ropes and through courses to get what
you want most of the challenges are just
the challenges of opportunity of just
st. taking the right thing on to be able
to fit like I have said yes a lot in the
past I'm just like oh we want you to
think about doing yeah okay you only
should maybe consider right even yes yes
and then you realize like oh I got to do
this like I have to get it done and they
want it on a deadline and I'm doing all
these other projects too and so in that
way it has been kind of just finding the
balance the work-life balance because
especially this year in the past the
past couple of years I've realized that
I don't have a life outside of work in
that way and so that maintaining that
balance is important to me but I'm also
just like these opportunities are slim
you know may not exist in in the future
and so that that fear is always driving
me to but it just feels like everyone is
so ready to listen right now everyone's
so ready to to give you a shot because
people are clamoring for for new voices
you just don't want to say yes to say
yes and I don't want to let anybody down
and that way or I let myself down most
importantly rule number eight get the
right feedback oh is someone that you
turn to for advice and it could be
professional advice or it could just be
life advice there's someone that you
feel like when you need that advice you
can pick up the phone and call that
person you're closer friend very close
to my friends and I actually like
outside of the industry advice because I
feel like sometimes we're just so heavy
and we're so in it so I like to get the
perspective and just like it's not that
serious
it's so important for me to get other
perspective outside my friends that rule
number nine grow others you created a
community around yourself of people and
started working on something and writing
and that's how you got to insecure yeah
I mean it was for sure like that was
working with the people around me I
think when you do something on your own
first thing you show that you're serious
and people will come and those people
started off as just friends my friends
know me and they know that when I say
that I'm gonna do something at least
professionally that I do it and so it
was about doing that and then when I
needed help like hey girl I am I need
someone to do the lighting I need you to
be in this I need extra bodies no man
come through and like using that that
network of people just that I met and
them lending like apartments and
locations when I needed it things like
that really helped meet up create the
product so that other strangers or even
their network of people would come and
be like yeah your sound sucks on this
episode my home he has my homey just
trying to go into sound can he ride yes
absolutely he's gonna work for free yeah
he just needs the experience and
literally from that that's really helped
to build just where I am today and so
much so that like people who have
started with since then
all of my friends have been appeared and
insecure in some way whether behind the
scenes are in front of the scenes it's
just like I love to grow with people and
it's it's the it's rewarding like you
know we're just all waiting at the end
of the day I read I would do the same
for them and rule number 10 the last one
before a very special bonus clip is have
fun never have I ever caught a celebrity
buy the wrong Navy yes and it still
pains me ah
I also congratulated my actors the night
of the Emmys for winning and I cleaned
it up i was like no but she should have
never have i ever been mistaken for
another celebrity and let it slide I was
mistaken for Jessica Williams look at my
face look at her face which is beautiful
but look at my face look at her face
[Applause]
this is getting nastier than
now I've got a really special bonus clip
from ISA ray on how to change the game
that I think you're really gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the three
point landing question it's time to move
from just watching another video to
taking action in your life for business
and if you're feeling bold leave your
answers in the comments below here we go
question number one what action do you
need to take on your ideas number two
what does balance look like to you
and number three where are you losing
your voice and need to speak up
I have a kind of creative is something I
started just out of my frustrations with
going through the television process and
you know the the pilot process that you
just felt very archaic and having come
from the internet I felt like I've been
able to create a couple of shows and
some of my peers and get an audience
around them and I feels like that is the
building block that is the proof that
there is an audience that wants this
content whereas the pilot process was
just like let's in a vacuum pay you to
write this this script three people will
approve it give notes and a year or two
years or three years will pass and maybe
it'll see the light of day maybe it
won't and then audience never gets to
see that and so I was like there's just
so many talented creators who just
purely create great stuff and they're
now they'll never get a chance to like
hack go through the television system so
color creative was made to just give
emerging writers of color and women the
opportunity to create their pilots and
to create their content and so for an
audience to see and so
if you want more Issa Rae check that the
first top ten rules reading are made on
her the link is right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there
stop making ceases you're the only one
stopping what I was trying to say in the
process because I was trying to make
what they wanted me to make